le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
il récompense les entrepreneurs
réunionnais depuis 1997
le challenge des créateurs fête ses 20
ans cette année
porté par le département et ses
partenaires ce concours met à l'honneur
des entrepreneurs en difficulté sociale
lors de la création de leur entreprise
des exemples d'audace de courage et de
réussite
à l'instar de muriel le bon cette
agricultrice a remporté le prix produit
pays l'an dernier
nous l'avons rencontrée chez elle au 17e
sur la commune du tampon
[Musique]
comme tous les matins muriel récupère
ses deux compères pour aller aux champs
à pioche le râteau les amoureux alors du
coup je vais enlever les mauvaises
herbes tout à la main alors il ya des
petits pois muriel est agricultrice sur
les hauteurs du tampon avec un c ap
coiffure en poche elle aurait dû manier
le peigne plutôt que le râteau mais
après quelques années de chômage cette
mère de famille décide de créer son
emploi alors ça fait deux ans que je
suis sur l'exploitation ça fait deux ans
que que je travaille tout seul
donc voilà j'essaie de me débrouiller
comme je peux c'est pas facile mais
j'essaie de trouver de nouvelles
techniques
c'est de faire quelque chose du ca pour
notre français muriel tente notamment de
faire revivre les légumes lontan comme
le songe
ah ça c'est la partie comme ici il ya
aussi mon sens bresson le battrons
twittant l'intérieur maulana fit sortir
le son lui mange tout le songe de croix
qui reste notre patrimoine alimentaire
du coup ça c'est le gros cave et genk
moi je vous montrais voilà c'est une
graine montant nos grands mais utiliser
ça avec un bon outil pour manger à ne
pas payer de produits p
[Musique]
les efforts de l'année aux agricultrices
ont porté leurs fruits l'an dernier
muriel a participé au challenge des
créateurs et elle n'est pas reparti les
mains vides
alors ça c'est le prix produit pays
le challenge des créateurs 2016 très
surprise étonné et hong kong mais aussi
au conseil départemental pas ce que
c'est
il met notre notre savoir faire lire et
puis une reconnaissance c'est important
la reconnaissance tout le travail est
pas facile c'est super ce moment à
reconnaître parce qu'on fait aussi des
belles rencontres
la réunion blues la réunion les jeunes
les moins jeunes tout le monde naseaux
idée chaque main à la pâte et puis il
fait avancer la réunion
le challenge des créateurs est un
concours organisé par le département et
ses partenaires le but promouvoir des
parcours d'entrepreneurs qui ont connu
des difficultés sociales connaissez les
difficultés de notre île
cent mille bénéficiaires du rsa nous
souhaitons activer les dépens de ce fait
d'arrêter cette affaire en sorte que un
bénéficiaire du rsa la base ils
deviennent lui aussi un créateur
d'entreprise vous savez qu'il ya des
aides spécifiques au département qui
existe comme par exemple dispositif
tremplin là en plus on va médiatiser
cette création d'entreprise et faire en
sorte que l'idée de ce créateur de celui
qui va se lancer elle est tout de suite
un retentissement dans la population
réunionnaise et tous ceux qui nous
regardent qui sont en attente d'un
emploi ils peuvent un moment donné se
dire pourquoi pas moi pourquoi pas créer
mon propre emploi en tant que lauréate
muriel a remporté six mille euros
une enveloppe qui lui permet de nourrir
ses ambitions comme ouvrir une table
d'hôte le prix du produit pays m'a
permis de faire les finitions de ma
table de tous
la fermture de la véranda ce qui dit
aluminium est ce que vous voyez en
finition cas les carreaux la peinture
une bonne évolution c'est parti le prix
elle a donné un petit coup de pouce donc
là un peu plus rapide donc les choses se
fait un peu plus rapidement
[Musique]
l'agricultrice prépare aussi un système
de vente par panier et envisage de se
tourner vers la permaculture c'est de
garder le côté naturel pour pas trop
embêter la nature pourquoi c'est nous
doit détruire dans l'entraînement ne pas
la connaître la nature on la travaille
désormais c'est dans la terre que muriel
puise l'énergie et la volonté d'aller de
l'avant
c'est un beau métier fatiguant parfois
parce que bon on a des choses et
plusieurs dates à planter mais sinon
super
[Musique]
le challenge des créateurs est un
concours porté par le département et ses
partenaires son objectif récompenser les
entrepreneurs en difficulté sociale
lors de la création de leur entreprise
plusieurs secteurs d'activité sont
représentés et pour les 20 ans du
concours cette année les lauréats
remporteront 7000 euros pour participer
au concours cette année
il faut être demandeurs d'emploi au
moment de la création d'entreprise
l'entreprise doit avoir au plus 18 mois
d'existence vous avez jusqu'au 31 août
pour vous inscrire au challenge des
créateurs 2017 sur le site du
département au www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]